get ready because we've got a list of
the most insane heartwarming and
jaw-dropping auditions from America's
Got Talent
if you're an a GT fan get ready to see
your favorite moments blow up on the
screen be sure to watch until the end to
see the biggest wow moment in egt
history here we go
the clairvoyants many have claimed to
have the gift of mind-reading but few
have pulled it off as well as the couple
on America's Got Talent
going all the way back to their very
first audition they impressed everyone
when Amelie guessed what was in Heidi's
handbag I quite like this shade it's
lipstick but the crazy thing about her
psychic abilities is how specific she
can get it in the next audition they had
Simon pull out a hundred dollar bill
from his wallet she was able to guess
the denomination and much to everyone's
surprise the entire serial number that
was printed on the bill and there is a
letter and there must be an A but how
could they top that
well they later had Mel B right the
initials of someone who has had a great
influence on her but she hasn't seen in
a while and they were able to guess her
grandmother's initials it's a B that is
correct yeah and even had her name
written on a piece of paper inside the
locket on her neck the best audition by
far was during the Champions finale
Heidi Mel be open your envelope and show
us your picture when they had how we
pull out that random picture of a hot
air balloon they later had him stick his
head in a cutout of a hot air balloon as
if they had known all along what was in
that random audience envelope they blew
everyone's minds with that one Sophie da
C if you want to see an inspirational
teenager look no further than a GT
Acrobat Sophie da see her first audition
had the Howie screaming whoa while
Heidi's jaw was practically on the floor
Sophie balanced on these tiny little
blocks while bending her body in half
and grabbing an apple with her feet that
she then fed herself with her feet you
we hope those feet were clean then she
shot a bow and arrow upside down and
backward with her feet the audience was
knees she started her next audition by
hanging from a hoop that was suspended
over the stage
seriously this girl has the strongest
neck muscles ever this audition was
explosive literally Sophie shot a
flaming arrow with her feet into a
target that burst into flames she got a
standing ovation that included her
mother clapping proudly and saying
that's my girl
but the biggest moment of the night was
when reba mcentire hit that gold buzzer
sophie was completely shocked but we're
not alone when we say she totally
deserved it
Sophie went on to show us that her
shoulders defy the laws of physics in
her semifinals audition and she had
everyone freaking out when she did all
those hoop tricks without a net
but the biggest jaw-dropping moment was
during her final audition that glowing
hoop routine seemed absolutely
impossible
seriously how fast was she spinning
Susan Boyle unless you've been living
under a rock for the last decade you've
heard of Susan Boyle and her fabulous
singing voice she first wowed the
audience and judges alike during her
audition on Britain's Got Talent and she
has been a sensation ever since she blew
everyone away when the unemployed 47
year old sang the song I dreamed a dream
from lame is Rob her life completely
changed after that performance
[Music]
she went on to sell over 25 million
records worldwide one of her most
impressive performances was during a GT
champions
she sang wild horses in the crowd
absolutely loved it so did the judges
[Music]
melb hit the gold buzzer sending her to
the finals Susan said she feels like
she's a champion for those who have
little confidence and for those who
don't have a voice and are ignored by
others Simon said she defined the show
and became an icon and how he said she
has been looking for that Susan Boyle
candidate ever since her first
performance it all started with that
beautiful song nine years ago so it only
made sense that she end her journey with
the same song on America's Got Talent
champions
she said she promised her mother she
would go after her dream to be a singer
while she didn't win champions
she certainly has fulfilled that promise
the rollerskating couple just like Susan
Boyle the rollerskating siblings Billie
and Emily England started out on
Britain's Got Talent
they freaked everyone out when Billie
Swan gamle by her feet and her head
seemed to come barely a centimeter away
from the floor but they took everyone's
breath away when they put that device
around their necks and he swung her
around in a circle it was insane
everyone was wondering how they were
going to top that but they blew everyone
away during their first audition on the
America's Got Talent stage they added
some crazy stunts that included the next
device and some new spinning pretzel
moves it was so scary Tyra Banks said
she needed therapy afterwards their
final performance on a GT was so
difficult and so painful Billy said they
couldn't even practice it he attempted
it for the first time live on the show
then Billy Swan gamle around while she
held onto his beard only it was so
intense that his beard hair was on the
floor when they were finished
Nobby called their performance stupid
and incredible they want a step further
when I'm least fun on Billy's head with
nothing but her pelvis Simon said their
act is terrifying and that their
absolute champions DJ arch he was the
youngest performer in the history of
South Africa's Got Talent at 3 years old
DJ arches first performance bought him
the gold buzzer on essays Got Talent at
his next performance he was up there by
himself while his dad waited in the
wings
his dad set up the music cues on two
brightly decorated laptops so the little
DJ could focus on the beads it worked
out well because he won the competition
that year fast forward to 2019 and the
now six year old DJ arch is vowing the
judges on the stage
America's Got Talent champions during
the behind-the-scenes portion of the
show
EJ's dad said that this little guy would
play with his dad's equipment at two
years old AJ said he loves music because
it makes him feel really cool
his performance got everyone on their
feet even though he didn't win champions
Simon said he has big plans for him and
that they should talk after the show AJ
is the youngest performer on any Got
Talent Show he also broke the Guinness
World Record for youngest DJ ever by the
looks of it DJ arches spinning career is
just beginning
DDF Cru this group won Holland's Got
Talent with their astonishing combo of
double dutch jump rope dance comedy and
acrobatics they did flips choreographed
dance routines and did jump rope tricks
and they really impressed the judges
their favorite part was the recreation
of that famous scene from Titanic when
Jack is at the front of the boat and
they didn't just use ropes they jumped
over canes and even used one of the guys
as a jump rope the glow-in-the-dark
sequence was pretty fun to watch but
during their performance on America's
Got Talent how he wasn't impressed the
rest of the judges loved it though the
audience didn't seem to agree with how
he and even booed him after the crew
left the stage Terry Crews interviewed
the crew members backstage afterwards he
asked what they thought of Howie's
comments one of the guys said that how
he is entitled to his opinion they
seemed to be doing just fine they're
performing their jump rope act
professionally and say they owe it all
to America apparently their obsession
with jump rope began when they saw an
American group jumping rope and they got
completely hooked on it
even though they didn't win the global
champions show this is just the
beginning for them light balance this
dance crews performance was literally
electric white balance came to America's
Got Talent all the way from Ukraine and
they brought a whole new level of
performance art to the stage entire
abanks knew they were something special
from the beginning because after their
performance she hit the bold buzzer the
level of effort involved in these
performances must be enormous in their
second audition they had a guy turn into
a werewolf on stage then there seemed to
be floating heads and legs it was like
he danced late
carnival did you guys catch the
performance where it seems like a guy
was flying through space and we're not
even sure how they made it look like the
werewolf was flying through the air in
slow motion this dance crew was able to
play with tricks of light and movement
that made seemingly impossible magic
happen on stage there were heads and
legs flying in different directions and
the audience loved it after those
performances they're probably booked for
a ton of entertainment gigs far into the
foreseeable future they have certainly
won the favor of the American audience
not to mention Tyra Banks we're still
trying to figure out how that werewolf
flew through the air like that Angelika
Hale if you haven't heard Angelica's
story yet you might want to pull out the
tissues this little songbird almost
never made it to the stage at four years
old she was diagnosed with double
pneumonia and her kidneys were failing
if her mother hadn't given her a
much-needed kidney Angelica would not
have made it
Angelica calls her mom her hero her
parents were tearful smiles as Angelica
walked onto the egt stage for the first
time at nine years old before she's
saying she announced that she just found
out that she was going to be a big
sister and right then she won the hearts
of everyone in America she said she
wanted to be the next Whitney Houston
and then she belted out the song rise up
and the judges were in love with her
they advanced her and she got the gold
buzzer not once but twice Angelica was
filled with excitement and gratitude
that she left a few tears on that stage
but she came back for her final
performance on champions and amazed
everyone again with her final song
impossible it came down to the finale of
egt champions and although Angelica did
not win the competition she is a
promising future as a singer and as a
big sister Darci Lin this 12 year old
ventriloquist from Oklahoma City made a
huge impression on Simon
[Music]
and the rest of the judges from the very
start she came out with her rabbit
puppet who goes by the name petunia and
saying summertime it was incredible the
judges were flabbergasted that she could
sing that well with her mouth closed
Darcy said that she started doing
ventriloquism because she was shy and it
helped her find her voice and come out
of her shell she was absolutely adorable
on stage Nobby gave her the gold buzzer
and everyone cried with her then she
introduced to more puppets a mouse named
Oscar who has a crush on Mel B later she
came out with an elderly puppet named
Edna door knocker
who's in love with Simon but when she
came back for the fourth time with both
Oscar the mouse and petunia the bunny it
was clear she was a champion Oscar yeah
but then she took it a step further for
the Champions finale when she performed
with Edna and roll the dog from the
Muppets
Simon was inspired to give Edna a kiss
on the cheek and America was inspired to
give Darcy her own show
proving that ventriloquism is still
alive and well chin limb chin limb has
been called the greatest sleight-of-hand
magician of all time from his first card
trick with Tyra Banks it was clear that
this guy has major talent he turned the
cards into a clear smoking pile before
they completely vanished seriously how
did he do that in his second appearance
on a GT the dude literally made cards
disappear before Olivia Munn and the
rest of the world dies petty called his
magic mind-blowing when he won America's
Got Talent he said it was a dream come
true but then he was invited back to be
on egt champions and that's when he
kicked the magic up a notch he had cards
smoking in his mouth and when how he
found the card inside his water cup he
was completely blown away Chin's final
performance was the most jaw-dropping of
them all he did a card trick for Melissa
Fumero he switched her card the queen of
diamonds even though it was in her mouth
and he took a picture of her with a
blank card at the beginning of the trick
on her phone and later the picture
showed the queen of diamonds totally
mind-blowing moment
it's no wonder Shen Lim was crowned
America's Got Talent global champion
what was your favorite age
audition tell us in the comments below
don't forget to subscribe to the things
to be the first to see our latest videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]